president biden goes fully radical by
declaring half the country akin to jim
crow racists
texas democrats fly private and live in
dc style while declaring they're
fighting for the people
and the biden state department says we
must answer for our racism
to the united nations i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressivevpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
that on july 4th
we declared our independence from
taxation from a government in ocean away
today our government
is the government that is imposing
heavy-handed and oppressive taxes while
at the same time
sending our wealth overseas driving the
value of the dollar into the ground
through reckless spending
now would be an excellent time to
protect your savings and declare your
financial independence for your savings
cut your ties to the us dollar invest in
gold and silver with the birch gold
group if you haven't reached out to
birch gold to diversify part of your ira
or 401k into a precious metals high
array
go ahead and do it today text ben 247
4747 get a free information kit i'm
protecting your savings
with gold i buy my gold from birch gold
they have an a plus rating with the
better business bureau countless five
star reviews
over ten thousand happy customers talk
to them have them help you safeguard
your investments text ben
247 4747 claim your free information kit
speak with a precious metals expert
on holding gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account again text ben to 47
47 47 and protect your savings today get
started with my friends
over at birch gold you should take at
least a little bit of your savings and
diversify
against the possibility of massive
inflation which we are already seeing or
the possibility of massive deflation too
i mean
gold is a hedge against all forms of
economic
volatility go check them out right now
over birch gold text been to 47
47 47 right now protect your savings
today alrighty so
the democrats are beginning to get
desperate and the reason they're getting
desperate is because it looks more and
more like 2022 is going to be a wave
election
for the republicans which always seems
to come as a shock to democrats and
members of the media
who since 2012 have declared to
themselves that
the political argument in the united
states is essentially over
in 2012 after barack obama won despite
winning fewer votes in 2012 than he did
in 2008
and despite his rather large-scale
unpopularity the unpopularity of
obamacare the
the lack of success of his financial aid
programs and the slow
economic growth he won re-election and
he did so on the basis of polarizing the
american population then appealing
two members of the american population
by racial and sexual orientation subset
and the democrats thought we have now
created a coalition for the future that
will never lose again and so in 2016
when donald trump won
it rocked their world this simply could
not be true it had to be some sort of
extraneous force that couldn't have been
productive predicted that undermined
their inevitable victory as they blamed
facebook
and they blamed and they blamed all
sorts of other extraneous factors they
couldn't
look harder at their own politics and
realize that they had caused all of this
well after joe biden won in 2020 the
democrats have done the same thing
they believe that they now have a
durable coalition that is never going to
lose again and so when they look at the
polls
and they realize that americans don't
much like their agenda that basically
joe biden's victory
hinged on him being an inanimate object
who wasn't going to do much
and now that joe biden has been pushing
this world-beating
large-scale progressive program most
americans are not into it that the
wokeness
from which joe biden has imbibed is
actually poisoning the party
the democrats have no good answer to
this and so they're beginning to panic
and so yesterday for example you saw
stephanie rule from msnbc
raising the question about a potential
red wave in 2022
she spoke with a political scientist
named rachel bite coffer about her
correctly predicting democratic gains
in 2022 and her concerns about
republican gains in 20
in 2018 rather and her concerns about
republican gains in 2022 and here is
what bite cover said
cities across the country are grappling
with a serious surge in violent crime
now republicans like former president
trump are seizing on that
to and seizing on that and trying to tie
democrats and their defund the police
messaging
to heading into next year claiming that
messaging is the reason for this spike
in crime
very bad news for democrats with a razor
thin house majority
and a tie in the senate if democrats do
not fight back
what are the odds of a red wave
they're excellent okay so the odds of
red wave are excellent democrats know
this rachel biden knows this and he
knows
that basically after 22 his presidency
is over
because if the republicans win back the
house in 2022 he no longer
has any ability to pass any of this
giant legislation he wishes to push he
understands that he is probably a
one-term president because he is fading
and fading quickly his daily battles
with the teleprompter are simply taking
it out
of the old man and this is a problem for
the democrats because waiting in the
wings
is the least charming politician in
modern america kamala harris who makes
hillary clinton look like cary grant in
terms of charm
and so the the fact that you've got a
party that is sort of on the ropes but
in control of all of the major levers of
the government
leads the democrats to some pretty
outrageous
maligning of their political opposition
they can't simply
push for their own agenda because their
own agenda is not particularly popular
instead
they have to claim that everybody on the
right is
a racist a sexist a bigoted homophobe
they've been doing this for years but
now
they've ratcheted it into high gear joe
biden a man who was elected as he said
in his inaugural address to unite
america
he was president for all americans the
ones who voted for him and the ones who
didn't vote for him
he was a president for everyone he was
going to bring the country together
around shared values well now joe biden
has declared that if you are for voter
id
or if you don't like universal mail in
voting or if you don't think that the
state government should send people
absentee ballots without them actually
having to apply for an absentee ballot
well this means that you're basically
akin to a jim crow racist and not just
that
anyone who promotes these policies is
inherently tied to the drugs and idiots
who decided to storm the capitol
building on january 6th
and so the rallying cry for the
democrats has been january 6th
now you may notice that january 6th
which was
again a bunch of idiots taking
president trump's words and then using
them as batons to wield against actual
police officers literal batons to wheel
against actual actual police officers
invading the capitol building you may
notice that the
100 million americans 150 million
americans who agree
generally with conservative policies
we're not involved in that
you might have noticed that but for
democrats you have to link the
outrageous
to the fully sane because that way you
can treat the fully sane as outrageous
and so this is what joe biden busily did
yesterday
joe biden gave a speech yesterday that
was the most polarizing of his
presidency thus far
which is saying quite a lot because he
has already declared that if you want to
pass voter id this means that you are
jim crow racist you remember he said
this over and over and over with regards
to this georgia voter law which was
actually
more permissive with regard to voting
than joe biden's home state of delaware
well joe biden did another speech
yesterday in which he suggested once
again
that you need to vote democrat not
because they are going to propose good
policies
not because they're going to fix any of
your problems you need to vote democrat
because the other guys
are jim crow racists who want to bring
us back to the civil war
now if you believe this i have to say
you're an idiot if you truly believe
that republicans in places like arizona
and georgia and texas are trying to
disenfranchise black people i would love
to see a shred of evidence
like any shred of evidence that this is
the intent or the
or the or the real impact because the
fact is the black population in the
united states
has been voting in very large numbers
the reason that rafael warnock is in the
senate in georgia is because black
americans voted in large numbers the
reason that barack obama was elected not
once but twice
is because of heavy black turnout so the
the notion that black people are having
their votes suppressed by the evil
republican party is just un it's
unmoored from reality
the same people who claim that it's
utterly insane for republicans to be
doing vote audits with regards to the
2020 election promote their own form of
conspiracism when they suggest that
republican voter id laws are going to
disenfranchise black people
by the hundreds of thousands or millions
but that's exactly what the president of
the united states is claiming
and he is linking that to the people who
decided it would be a great idea to
storm the capitol building and threaten
legislators
again without evidence so here is joe
biden labeling half the country the
enemy essentially
there's an unfolding
taking place in america today an attempt
to suppress and subvert
the right to vote and fair and free
elections
an assault on democracy an assault on
liberty
an assault on who we are
who we are as americans we're facing the
most significant test
of our democracy since the civil war
that's not hyperbole
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
uh he's using that's not hyperbole
the way that most other people who are
idiots use the word literally
now usually when your friend says
literally they mean not literally when
joe biden says this is not hyperbole
and then he and then he proceeds to
explain that voter id laws in states
like texas arizona florida
and georgia that these are the worst
threats to democracies since the civil
war
that is the dumbest thing i have heard
at least for the last seven minutes
from joe biden it is impressively stupid
no need to go through the you know
century-long history of jim crow where
black people were actively
disenfranchised
in states across the country where black
people were told that they had to pass a
literacy test in order to vote that they
had to be poll taxed in order to vote
when black people were actively pushed
out of voting booths when
their families were threatened if they
voted no this is just like that
according to joe biden it's the worst
threat since the civil war that's nuts
it's crazy and it's not just that that's
crazy
it's vicious because he is labeling half
the country who simply wants to see
voter procedures shored up and who have
serious questions about the conduct in
the last election by the way
i don't think you have to think the last
election was stolen to have serious
questions about why it was for example
that the pennsylvania supreme court
decided to simply overrule the
pennsylvania state constitution
and rewrite voter law in pennsylvania i
don't think you have to think
that the last election was stolen or
that donald trump was the actual winner
in order to wonder
about the veracity of large-scale mail
and balloting
as a as a trustable form of voting
generally speaking
you can mitigate risks without having to
say that the last election was stolen
but joe biden wants to tie all this
stuff together and wrap a bow on it and
then say that his political opponents
are exactly the same kinds of people
who are rushing at the capitol building
so here is joe biden continuing along
this path again
he's lumping together everybody who
agrees with voter id which by the way is
more than half the country
if you take polls more than half of
black americans agree with voter id
he's lumping together all these people
with people who stormed the capitol
building
and then also with confederates
apparently here is joe biden labeling
more than half the country again the
enemy
in america if you lose
you accept the results you follow the
constitution you try again
you don't call facts fake
and then try to bring down the american
experiment just because you're unhappy
that's not statesmanship that's
selfishness
that's not democracy it's the denial of
the right to vote
okay i have to say that there there is
something
truly maddening about the fact that joe
biden goes out there and gaslights
like this he says things like if you
lose an election you just accept that
you lost the election
weird because for four years we heard
from democrats including people like joe
biden
that russian collusion had decided the
election we had adam shift out there
every day on national television on cnn
wolfe blitzer breaking news
that there was going to be some sort of
fact that emerged showing that the
russians had subverted the 2016 election
and that the actual president of the
united states should have been hillary
clinton
we saw this for four years we saw the
intelligence apparatus of the united
states under barack obama
militarized against michael flynn for
example we saw
the intelligence apparatus target carter
page with a bad fisa warrant
based on the steele dossier which turned
out to be a gussied up piece of a dnc
operative junk
and then he has the temerity to talk
about accepting election results
according to democrats there hasn't been
a legitimate republican president
elected in this country since 1988.
k2000 was a stolen election according to
democrats 2004 was only a result of
2000.
2016 was a stolen election according to
democrats so
i'm i'm having a hard time see stacy
abrams is the legit governor of georgia
according to the democratic party
so i'm just wondering who exactly on the
left has been in the habit of accepting
election
results when they go the wrong way i i'm
missing it
it seems like this is a problem that
seems to be spanning all parties because
respect for american institutions
has hit the toilet in the last decade
particularly
everybody didn't stop there joe biden
then suggested that republicans today
are pushing 21st century jim crow this
is so insulting to people actually lived
during jim crow
it's so unbelievably insulting if you
believe that your attempts to vote in
are akin to your grandfather's attempts
to vote in 1952 alabama
you need to have your head examined or
you're dropped as a baby or both
here is joe biden saying a morally
egregious thing and and the media is
just going along with this i'm noticing
that there are not any sort of chirons
from cnn about how this isn't true even
though it is quite clearly not true
here is joe biden saying a quite clearly
untrue and morally benighted thing
this year alone 17 states have enacted
not just proposed but enacted 28 new
laws
to make it harder for americans to vote
not to mention
and catch this nearly 400 additional
bills
republican members of the state
legislatures are trying to pass
the 21st century jim crow assault is
real
it's unrelenting it is not a jim crow
like he lived through jim crow hell he
was friends with half the jim crow
senators
so um joe biden doesn't according to
kamala harris who's people like joe
biden who tried to stop little girls
from her
like going to from going to desegregated
public schools and this tool bag is out
there saying that we're experiencing a
new 21st century jim crow
in what magical world are we
experiencing a 21st century
jim crow right now the most celebrated
figures in america today
are black intellectuals or
pseudo-intellectuals like nicole hannah
and jones and ta-nehisi codes we had a
black president twice joe biden is only
a household name because he served as
vice president under
that black president black voters
outrepresent
outstrip the percentage of the
population in national elections these
days in what way is this anything
remotely like jim crow but again
they need the specter of jim crow in
order to turn off your brain
right if you just listen to joe biden
you can't even consider voting for a
republican because after all
these people are all basically bull
conor these people all just want to stop
black people from voting
it's a lie it's an overt absolute lie
and the media go along with it of course
because they're not just going along
with it they're propaganda outfits
now this is the thing that is truly
undermined our our faith in our
institutions it used to be that if you
didn't have faith in american
institutions
at least you had some fate the media was
going to hold those institutions
accountable
when the media decide that they are just
the propaganda outlet for the
institution so long as the institutions
are run by democrats
that's when republicans start to feel
like all of the odds are stacked against
them to the point
where they can no longer have their
voices heard through any process
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because truly the the
supposed calm unifying president of the
united states
is actually just a a senility ridden
radical
and it's it's an ugly prospect for the
country we'll get to more of this in
just one second first
let us talk about your investment
strategy wall street has been fibbing
for years saying that a measly few
percent is a good return on your stocks
well it doesn't have to be
trading is so complex you need a
financial advisor they say well
maybe you don't all you need is
carnivore trading where they are
crushing it even when the market is
tough carnivore trading is an anonymous
team of elite strategists they're
legends among wall street heavy hitters
they've gone a bit rogue because for the
first time
they're inviting everyday folks like you
like me to see and mirror their
explosive trading strategy it sounds too
good to be true carnivore will let you
see the trades they are making right now
for two weeks for free
go to getourtrades.com use promo code
ben
for two free weeks if you join you'll
get carnivore's industry leading promise
that you'll generate three times your
fees
after your annual paid subscription or
you will get a 100 refund which is
pretty good deal go to getourtrades.com
promo code ben
that's getourtrades.com promo code ben
see website for guaranty terms and
conditions past performance not a
guarantee of future earnings go check
them out right now get
our trades.com promo code ben carnivores
attempting to open up trading to people
who may not be fluent in it go check
them out right now get our trades.com
use promo code ben alrighty so and this
is the democratic line and now in order
to fight the supposed republican
jim crow assault this means that
democrats have every ability to
undermine the actual functioning
workings of democracy it's really
impressive do you see the
the unbelievable gaslighting and flip
here so the idea here is that
republicans are subverting elections by
saying that voters
should have verifiable means of voting
that is subverting elections that is the
new jim crow
meanwhile texas texas democrats in order
to stymie republicans
from pursuing this new jim crow get to
simply abscond from the state of texas
violate the law and shut down basic
majoritarian democracy
in texas and unlike on the national
level where we have a 50-50 split
in the senate there is no 50-50 split in
texas republicans have an overwhelming
majority
in the state assembly in texas and so
democrats came up with a strategy they
didn't want to pass this voter id law
they didn't want to pass a couple of
bills that suggested that boys should
play with boys and girls with girls
in sports and so they got on a plane and
they flew to washington dc
in order to deny republicans a quorum
and these are the heroes of the day
according to the media
if you undermine democracy by simply
walking out of the chamber and leaving
the state
so that you can't be brought back to the
chamber to vote in majoritarian fashion
now you're a hero you see the filibuster
is bad a long-held standard in the
united states senate that's supposed to
promote
debate and and conciliation that's
really bad and anti-democratic but
if an entire political party in texas
picks up that's on a private jet and
flies to washington dc while patting
themselves on the back
in order to deny the workings of
democracy that's not only not
anti-democratic it is pro-democratic you
see
now you may be saying yourself i don't
see a consistent standard here correct
you don't there is none
there is no consistent standard when it
comes to the democratic party and the
media the answer is whatever forwards
the agenda is good and whatever does not
forward the agenda is jim crow
and joe biden is fully on board with
this because the way you hold political
power according to joe biden
is you gin up an enormous amount of faux
outrage
and then you claim that your political
opponents are the equivalent of george
wallace standing in a schoolhouse door
okay so texas democrats have sconded
over the course of the last couple of
days
they just picked up and they got a
private jet and they left and they
partied it up
in fact uh they were they were bragging
about what a wonderful time they were
having in washington dc these are true
emissaries of the people by the way they
got in a private jet
and they brought along a case of miller
light just in case any of them decided
that
their drinking habit couldn't last for
the four hour flight from
texas from austin to to washington dc
gene wu a texas legislature tweeted out
a a picture of what appears to be a
caesar salad with croutons
he said my fist meal as a fugitive i
assume he meant a first meal
i don't want to know what he does in the
privacy of his own home so my fist meal
is a fugitive
delicious what a hero and then he
tweeted out again
landed safely in dc officially out of
arrested jurisdiction of governor abbott
it was wonderfully to random it was
wonderfully to randomly run into people
who recognize me and applauded what we
are doing yes i'm sure that that was
happening a lot i'm sure that people
were just randomly running into this
anonymous state legislator and they were
like that guy's a hero and then
you have a hero shot a bunch of texas
state legislators
are standing very solemnly but happily
in front of the united states capital
because nothing says
appealing to texas voters quite like
absconding to washington dc
and asking the federal government to
step in and quash the workings of the
texas state legislature
really really solid texas legislative
stuff one of the congress people tweeted
out it takes a village
on the bus from dulles to dc last night
doing the lawrence o'donnell show oh the
heroism oh
she was doing the lawrence o'donnell
show from her cell phone my god it's
like normandy
julie johnson of texas held the camera
light see ordaz perez plugged in my
phone to her computer as it was dying
ramos for texas found the bus outlet
hashtag women helping women yes
it's just like malala yousafzai trying
to stump for
afghan women not being crammed into
basements and and clubbed and
acided in the face for for the crime of
going to school these that's women
helping women
women helping women is making sure that
the camera is steady while you do a hit
on lawrence o'donnell
from your plush chartered bus to
washington dc
oh the heroism they're stopping jim crow
guys so much stopping
of the jim crow okay so some of these
texas democrats have been asked about
their obvious
hypocrisy and the ridiculousness of of
flying first class private jet
no masks to dc to appeal for the federal
government's help
and uh one texas democrat says you know
we need to fly private we're just it's
like john kerry
i i need to fly private i can't
i'm important i can't fly with the
peasants the peasants smell
and have chickens there is a texas
democrat explaining
why they need they must fly private
when you break a quorum you want to be
successful so i think everybody wants to
see
you know 51 52 55 democrats on the same
plane that's reassuring number two
uh you know to get a flight out of town
uh at a time certain with
you know getting everybody to come in
from across the state you need to fly
privately
and as you can see from the picture
we're talking about using the same kind
of
plane that the public uses every day
there's no there's no fancy couches or
anything like that this was just a
regular plane that moved us from one
state to another
well you know they needed to because
they needed the reassuring picture of
all the texas democratic legislators
fleeing the state it the the sort of
self-congratulatory nature of this that
that's just the beginning
texas democrats then in in one of the
most cringe-worthy political videos
of the last couple of years they gather
together to sing we shall overcome
you know like the civil rights anthem we
shall overcome because it turns out that
stumping against voter id and making
sure that biological boys can play
against girls
and then absconding from the state in
order to ensure that requires you
to sing civil rights marching songs as
though you are martin luther king and
selma
these people are a joke
we will overcome we will never
my kid's talent show right there that is
that is not that is not good stuff
number one somebody get somebody who can
sing number two
you know i'm noticing usually when
people do civil rights marches and they
sing things like we shall overcome i'm
noticing an awful lot of
lack of anyone giving a crap i see the
difference in selma and that is you know
the dogs the hoses
the armed police here it's just a bunch
of texas democrats standing there and
their arm has stretched three inches
from their from their inability to pat
themselves on the back properly
without an actual physical arm
stretching unbelievable stuff okay we'll
get some more of this in just one second
because again these people are fighting
jim crow they're fighting the worst
excesses we have seen
since the civil war said every idiot in
the media
first let us talk about a truly
meaningful gift if you want to give a
truly meaningful gift you need to try
paintyourlife.com you get a professional
hand-painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price
you can choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect
they've got a user-friendly platform
unless you order a custom-made
hand-painted portrait in less than five
minutes you can send any picture
whether it's yourself your kids your
family a special place cherished pet
or you can also combine photos into one
painting which is really useful if you
can't get your entire family together
at paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded i know they're great
because we have a giant portrait
of me and my wife and two of our three
kids we need to order a new one from
paintyourlife.com
right now actually because we have now a
baby squishy and it has added to our
family so that means we need a new
portrait you should get one right now as
well
if you don't love that final painting
your money is refunded guaranteed right
now as a limited time offer get twenty
percent off your painting that is
correct 20
off and free shipping to get this
special offer text the word ben
to 64 000 that has been to 64 000 once
again text ben
to 64 000 today paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
terms apply available at paint your life
dot com slash terms
again text ben to 64 000 today to get
started on a fantastic fantastic gift
for your family or for yourself or for
somebody you love alrighty so
the texas democrats they are just they
are over the moon about their own
heroism here
and they're being helped out of course
by national democrats
kamala harris uh she came out and she
said these people they're they're such
heroes oh the heroes
oh the the um oh the world breaking
heroism
it's like the end of independence day
when that guy took the biplane up into
the belly
of that giant alien spaceship and then
blew it out it's just like that it's
unreal i mean just such heroism
it just makes you want to cry here's
kamala harris i'm being utterly
insincere as a that this is her only
mode by the way
she's sort of like ash from alien if she
starts to look too sincere she starts to
anyway here she goes i know what you
have done
comes with great sacrifice both personal
and political
and you are doing this in support and in
defense
of some of our nation's highest ideals
reporters ask me well you know what do
you think about the issue i say look
defending the right of the american
people
to vote is as american as apple pie
and then she's like on the verge of like
you can never tell whether she's on the
verge of laughing
which it makes things very awkward and
weird like what's she gonna do
i don't know what's happening here i do
love her her line there
the sacrifice you are undertaking oh the
unbelievable sacrifice of being booked
on lawrence o'donnell and somebody
having to plug in your phone so it
doesn't run out of battery the
incredible sacrifice of being welcomed
by the vice president of the united
states and then
heaped with praise it's like jesus on
the cross it's like the
it's like these offerings that were
offered in the temple i mean it's
the the incredible sacrifice it's like
the the men of world war
ii storming beaches at normandy i've
never seen it's like the civil rights
marchers willingly
being beaten in the streets for their
beliefs that's you getting on a private
jet eating a crouton salad and then
sitting with kamala harris while she
talks about how wonderful you are
the sacrifice oh oh my mind shattering
my galaxy brain sacrifice there from
these texas
democrats so she she met with them
yesterday
joe manchin was also expected to meet
with the democratic members of the texas
legislature
although um a date and time have not
been set yet
this all is geared toward pressuring
mansion really because really the
solution that democrats are proposing
is not what will eventually happen texas
democrats go back to their houses and
nothing happens and republicans pass
their bill
instead what they are attempting to do
is leverage joe manchin
into passing the for the people act
which is this garbage federalization of
all voting policy including
mass ballot harvesting including
outlawing voter id in the original
iteration
what they want is for joe manchin to
throw out the filibuster and so they're
gonna try and pressure him with all of
these dumb tactics
and again this is something the media
love to do with texas and they did this
with wendy davis a few years
back when wendy davis was was yelling
about how she she loved abortion and she
was wearing
pink shoes and just oh she was she was
such a heroine and then she ran for
governor and just got absolutely swamped
by greg abbott it's the same thing with
texas democrats
meanwhile the the texas governor says
you know i can't just arrest you
and if you come back here i can't arrest
and by the way he does have the legal
ability
to arrest them okay under under texas
law
the rule is that you can basically go
compel
legislators to show up because they
understand that this is sort of a
problem
that if you're denied quorum it stops
all of the business
according to house rules adopted at the
beginning of the regular session
according to the texas tribune
two-thirds of the 150 member chamber
must be present to conduct business when
the house is in session
legislators can vote to lock chamber
doors to prevent colleagues from leaving
and can order law enforcement to track
down lawmakers who have already fled
if a quorum is not present when the
house convenes any house member can move
to make known
what's what's known as a call of the
house to quote secure and maintain a
quorum to consider a certain piece of
legislation resolution or motion under
chamber rules that motion must be
seconded by 15 members and ordered by a
majority vote if that happens the
missing democrats become legislative
fugitives
it's just like here i mean they're such
heroes like harrison ford they're going
to throw themselves over a waterfall
while tommy lee jones goes i don't care
the house rules say all absentees for
whom no sufficient excuse is made may by
order of majority of those present be
sent for and arrested wherever they may
be found by the sergeant-at-arms where
an officer appointed by the
sergeant-at-arms for that purpose their
attendance shall be secured and retained
the house shall determine on what
conditions they shall be discharged now
it's difficult to compel democrats to
show the reason they fled the state is
because it's difficult to send
like the texas rangers over to
washington dc to pick up these uh these
ridiculous texas state legislators the
house voting bill is passed by the
committee over the weekend would reign
in local voting initiatives like
drive-through and 24-hour voting
because as it turns out 24-hour voting
is very difficult to keep tabs on
but further tighten the rules for voting
by mail bolster access for partisan poll
watchers and ban local election
officials from proactively sending out
applications to request
mail-in ballots okay so that is where
things currently
stand meanwhile the texas again the
texas state
democrats are so obnoxious i'm just on
on an objective level they are obnoxious
texas state representative
james talarico tweeted out this he
tweeted out
come and take it i said here's my
response to governor abbott he's gonna
arrest us
come and take it oh come and take it
and what what what a hero james tell us
such such heroism mitch mcconnell riley
pointed out
i've noticed that you guys are suddenly
very concerned about legislative
minority rights um you're the same
people who want to wreck the filibuster
on the federal level so that's weird
i've noticed that the
the democrat minority in the kentucky
in the texas legislature is up here
today and i think it's uh
quite interesting to see the democratic
majority in the senate concerned about
minority rights
in the state senate in texas
i guess if you live long enough you'll
see almost anything around here
true enough but again this is all part
and parcel of the broader democratic
push which is going to fail by the way
because americans don't believe this
they do not believe that we are on the
verge of a new jim crow because we
aren't they don't believe that
republicans are attempting to widely
suppress the vote because they're not
and there's no evidence of that and so
if this is the best democrats can do
they're going to get swamped
and the reason they're going to get
swamped is because they suck at this it
turns out that standing a thwart the
government and shouting at donald trump
is a lot more lucrative politically than
actually having to run the country and
democrats have been focused on blowing
out the budget
and backing woke movements that are
anti-american in orientation
we'll get to that in just one second
because the bite administration foreign
policy
is really heading down a pretty ugly
path right now like a seriously ugly
path right now we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that if you are a
responsible human being you need to make
sure that your family has
life insurance if you're walking across
the street and you get hit by a tractor
trailer you need to make sure that your
family is at least financially okay and
that is why
life insurance is necessary but most
people get life insurance through word
of mouth this is a dumb way to get life
insurance you should competitively shop
it
like you do everything else you can do
that at policygenius.com policy genius
makes it easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top insurers all in one
place why i compare
i could say 50 or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with policy genius
it could save 1300 bucks or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies
the licensed experts and policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius thousands of five-star views
across trustpilot and google
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call
this exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes higher than options
from ladder
ethos and bestow getting started is
simple first head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price
when you're ready to apply the policy
genius team will handle the paperwork
and the scheduling for free
policy genius never sells your
information to other companies and they
don't add on extra fees head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice
and important to get it right alrighty
we'll get some more on this in just
one second first this week we saw a man
dressed as an over-sexualized rainbow
monkey
employed by a library to teach children
to read yes good times even worse than
this is the normalization of such events
by the left it's a symptom of the
culture we are living in and i explain
why in my new book the authoritarian
moment
in it i hope people understand as much
as they can about how we reach this
point how we can all begin to fight back
here's the thing if you're a
conservative even a moderate
in american society even if you're a
moderate liberal in american society
you feel it we all feel it we feel that
there is this extraneous
exorbitant pressure from the major
institutions of our society
to agree and if you don't celebrate
ridiculous things like rainbow
monkeys teaching your children then you
will be
just you'll be destroyed they will cast
you out into the cornfield there's
something wrong
with you the institutions of the united
states have been renormalized and
weaponized against traditional values
how that happened that's the subject of
my new book the authoritarian moment and
more importantly the book is about how
to fight back against that
it's a really important book it's now
available for pre-order at amazon
barnes and noble or any other major book
seller so go get your copy
right now also if you know candace owens
you know she's always got something
interesting to say
and if you know her show you can know
pretty much anything can happen like
last night's interview with ufc fighter
benell terrius where they examined his
love for america and his stand against
the marxist ideology that affected his
family the episode dropped last night be
sure to go check it out
right now watch candace on demand right
now if you haven't subscribed yet we're
giving 25
off new memberships with code candace at
dailywire.com subscribe and
make sure you grab the audio podcast on
apple spotify or whatever
your platform of choice may be you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
alrighty so meanwhile the biden
administration while declaring that you
know american racism is an all-time high
and that jim crow is on the way
while they run the entire government by
the way
they are now pursuing they're pursuing
an anti-american policy it's an
anti-american foreign policy
i don't know how else to describe this
tweet from secretary of state anthony
blanken now i've given blink and credit
in the past
for for example saying some relatively
decent things about the israel gaza
conflict for example
i've given blinken and the foreign
policy team some credit for the things
that joe biden said with regards to
vladimir putin but this is truly
egregious and the fact that it's been
largely overlooked by the media is
insane to me so he tweeted this out i
completely missed this until one of my
producers made me aware of it this
morning
it's wild secretary of state lincoln
tweeted this quote
responsible nations must not shrink from
scrutiny of their human rights record
rather they should be transparent with
the intent to grow and do better
that is why i'm announcing a formal
invitation for the un
special rapporteur on contemporary forms
of racism to visit the united states
this is patently mad i mean it's crazy
the united nations
is a is most easily of international
politics it is a wretched hive of scum
and villainy
the the notion that we should have
auditors from sudan
and china and russia and malaysia and
all of these other countries that
can't hold a candle boss in terms of
human rights come and audit
domestic american racism it's a
political tool by anthony blinken
which so often foreign policy is to
democrats and this is why barack obama
in his very early days before he was
even president
did a european tour a lot of people in
the united states were saying themselves
why is barack obama a senator in the
united states running for the american
presidency attempting to go abroad and
do speeches
in like berlin and paris and the answer
is because what democrats really wish to
do
is suggest that other countries their
opinions ought to matter with regards to
domestic american politics the rest of
the world is judging
us it's sort of greta tunberg syndrome
writ large they're judging you
that judge and so anthony blinken
literally wants to have members of the
un come and judge
american racism that's pathetic and it's
anti-american
no one has the moral stature to come
into the united states
the most racially diverse place on earth
most racially diverse democracy on
planet earth and most racially tolerant
diverse democracy on planet earth by the
way
and then start lecturing us on how
racist we are and the fact that this
administration is welcoming them in
they're welcoming them in in the same
way that the department of justice under
merrick garland
is going to go into police departments
and simply make up reports about how
police departments are racists and then
cram down consent decrees the idea here
will be the u.n issues report on how
terrible and racist america is and
there it is magically the only way to
alleviate this deep and brutal and
abiding racism is to do all the things
that joe biden wants to do
so joe biden and anthony blinken can't
convince you that america is racist and
terrible
so they will bring in international
institutions to call america racist and
terrible
and deride the united states on the
international stage so they can say we
need to do all the things we already
wanted to do
because after all the world expects it
of us it's not who we are
it's so shameless and it's so yucky
okay the the reality is that as i talked
about on the show yesterday and the day
before
to most people who are seeking freedom
on planet earth the united states is the
place you go
the united states is the place you go
for racial tolerance the united states
has a higher household income for
nigerian americans than does for white
americans has a higher household income
for asian americans than for white
americans
for for a supposedly white supremacist
country we're doing a horrible job of it
here in the united states
and yet the continuous push from the
democrats that america is deeply racist
and the whole goal here is to mobilize
minority voters who supposedly are going
to fight
the revanchist republican racism that
inevitably will fall
despite the fact that again it does not
exist and it is very silly
now all of this is part and parcel of
treating american foreign policy is
basically a domestic political weapon
it's not about spreading american values
abroad it's not about liberating people
it's not about insuring a safer and more
secure world for american interests it's
not about any of those things
it's about forwarding democratic
domestic political interests it's all
wag the dog crap it is all about doing
things that benefit
the democrats politically domestically i
mean that is why jobiden is pulling out
of afghanistan make no mistake that is
not about forwarding american interests
it's not about making america more safe
and it is not about protecting american
troops it is about joe biden
wanting to be able to say that he
withdrew from afghanistan unlike all of
his predecessors
and then thinking that the american
people are going to cheer even as women
are stuffed back into burqas
and stuff back into basements and the
taliban take over the country and
continue to foster terrorism in the
region
because joe biden wants the political
win it is that simple
and now when secretary blinken is
welcoming in un special reporters
to talk about american racism you know
how much i care about what the u.n has
to say about anything having to do with
morality
this this turd bucket of an organization
i i could not care less
what the union has to say about anything
the un is a is a
is a despicable
dumpster fire of an organization where
we're supposed to take seriously
countries
like yemen on human rights no the answer
should be by any patriotic president and
any patriotic administration no
but instead we're actively seeking out
the opinions of the un on american
racism which of course is designed
solely to create pressure domestically
and meanwhile speaking of people we
apparently refuse to judge
the iranians right the biden
administration has been desperate to
make a nuclear deal with the iranians
again
not because the united states under
biden believes that it's in our best
interest to make a nuclear deal with
iran
no it's all about domestic political
consumption it's about the idea that he
gets a win
for someone putting his name on a piece
of paper even if he's neville
chamberlain
and the mullahs are hitlerian put his
name on a piece of paper and he gets the
diplomatic win
and this is what barack obama did and he
signed an iran nuclear deal and then
it was touted by the media as a big win
even though it actually fostered iranian
terrorist regime
power in the region well now we have a
story and you'll notice the discrepancy
between how the media covered this story
and how the media covered for example
the saudi killing of jamal khashoggi was
a muslim brotherhood associated
journalist who would write for the
washington post you remember that jamal
khashoggi
was murdered at the saudi embassy in
turkey
and this became an international scandal
and it caused a rift between the united
states and the saudi administration
media were really pushing that rift hard
well now
we have news that iranian operatives
planned to kidnap a brooklyn author
so the iranians referring to kidnap an
iranian-american journalist living in
brooklyn
according to the new york times who's
been a sharp critic of the iranian
government and was the target of an
international kidnapping
plot orchestrated by an intelligence
network in iran according to federal
prosecutors
in an indictment unsealed in federal
court in manhattan four iranians were
charged with conspiring to kidnap the
journalist and author
masih al-anishad mr lindachat was not
identified by prosecutors but confirmed
in an interview she was the intended
targeted target of the plot
last year alinashad wrote in a newspaper
article the iranian government
had unleashed a social media campaign
calling for her abduction the four
dependent defendants all live in iran
and remain at large the prosecutors said
a fifth dependent
defendant rather accused of supporting
the plot but not participating in the
kidnapping conspiracy was arrested
in california the indictment describes a
plot that included attempts to lure alex
alinajad an american citizen to a third
country to capture her
and forcibly render her to iran so very
much the same thing that the saudis were
doing to
shaggy although khashoggi was in fact
not an american national
intelligence official mr farahani and
his network used private investigators
to surveil photograph and video record
alina shot and members of her household
in brooklyn
so the iranians were seeking to kidnap
an american who was critical of them
and then essentially rendition her back
to iran where presumably should have
been jailed or executed
here is the response from the american
state department it's astonishing
again this is the the foreign policy
being pursued by this administration is
not in the interest of the united states
it is
blatantly anti-american when you are
when you are poo pooing
an administration that's attempting to
actively kidnap americans because you
want to sign an appeasement deal with
them uh
i don't know what else to call that
except anti-american here is the state
department statement you ready
quote the iranian government continues
to deny iranians their rights
including through severe restrictions on
the rights to peaceful assembly freedom
of association freedom of religion and
belief
and freedom of expression the biden
administration will continue to call out
and stand up to iran's human rights
abuses
and will support others who do so both
here and in iran this is a law
enforcement matter
and we refer you to the department of
justice for any further inquiries oh is
it a law enforcement matter
because it seems to me it's an
international relations matter
when a foreign country attempts to
abduct an american citizen critical of
them
it seems that that might implicate our
foreign policy
but you see how the biden administration
wants to sever any connection between
their appeasement of iran and iran
attempting to abduct an american citizen
these are the same people by the way who
are endlessly critical of the saudi
regime for what they did to khashoggi
and largely correctly so when it comes
to iran suddenly
they've lost all willpower to link this
to foreign policy at all
not a shock at all because again the
policy of the biden administration
is to downplay any sort of rift or
conflict with
totalitarian countries and to uplay the
notion that the real threat to america
is domestic
and republican in form the real
authoritarians you need to worry about
are texas republicans
not cuban dictators or iranian mullahs
or chinese dictators
or or or russian authoritarians you have
to worry about any of those people the
people you need to worry about most are
your next door neighbors who voted for
trump
those are the people who are the
greatest threat meanwhile by the way
i've noticed
it is astonishing how uh how quickly the
biden administration has flipped so
you'll remember that during the
trump administration there are a bunch
of syrian refugees and there's a lot of
talk about how many syrian refugees we
ought to allow into the country
and trump limited the number of syrian
refugees on the basis that we couldn't
vet
who these folks were we didn't know they
were going to integrate well into the
united states maybe we should seek
third party places for them to live
maybe they could be taken in turkey
maybe they could be taken in other
muslim countries there was no way to vet
the people who are coming in
however there is a very very long
history in the united states of taking
in
cuban refugees right people have been
floating
the chevys from 1954 off the coast of
cuba
and to miami in an attempt to find
freedom and in fact
the miami community which is filled with
cuban american expatriates
is one of the most patriotic communities
in the united states they love the
country they love founding values
because they understand the evil they
understand the evils of communism
well yesterday alejandro mayarkas made
clear that anybody
who attempts to float from cuba to
florida will immediately
be turned back he said you will not come
to the united states here is mayorkas
allow me to be clear if you take
to the sea you will not come
to the united states the time is never
right
to attempt migration by sea to those who
risk their lives
doing so this risk is not worth taking
again i repeat do not risk your life
attempting to enter the united states
illegally
i've noticed that it was the same by the
administration to the end this
administration was attempting to end the
third party holding of people
who were applying for asylum status in
mexico and they were saying no
people shouldn't have to stay in mexico
in order to apply for asylum so if
you're crossing the mexican border
then presumably that's okay we're
supposed to catch you and we're supposed
to release you according to the biden
administration
if however you flee cuba because you
hate communism
and you do so at the risk of your life
and your family's life
by floating a derelict craft 90 miles
through shark-infested waters to florida
then we are going to pick you up the
coast guard's going to pick you up and
drop you right back off in cuba
hmm i wonder what the difference could
be between their treatment
of the cubans or attempting to escape an
actual communist tyranny
and people who are attempting to cross
the american southern border not because
they are fleeing tyranny
not because they are seeking asylum but
simply because they are seeking economic
opportunity in the united states weird
i wonder what what the difference could
be could it be that a huge percentage of
the people who are coming through the
mexican border
are likely to vote democrat and a huge
percentage of the people who are
floating from cuba to florida are likely
to vote republican
could that have anything to do with it
i'm seeing some weirdness here
and i'm not seeing alexander
ocasio-cortez crying on the coast of
florida
i'm not seeing her in her white outfit
weeping at the inherent cruelty
of taking families who have braved again
shark-infested waters for 90 miles
attempting to float cars
to escape communists here i'm not seeing
her weeping on the coast
i'm not seeing the kids in cage's
headlines anymore very very strange
very strange except of course that it is
not strange
once again it's about domestic politics
because for the biden administration
it's always about domestic politics and
if we have to
make american interests subservient to
the domestic politics of the democratic
party that is precisely what we will do
let me repeat it is unpatriotic to
welcome the united nations to do a
report
on supposed american racism let me
repeat
there's a wild inconsistency in the
department of homeland security
suggesting that we should let everyone
through the southern border of the
united states but no one
arrived in cuba from cuba to florida
the there is something going on here but
it is not anything remotely approaching
a consistent policy it remains a rather
shocking development that this
administration
has gotten as radical as it did i mean
some of us were warning about it right
some of us were warning this was bernie
sanders with uh joe biden's
face on it that basically this
administration was was
bernie sanders is hannibal lecter and
he's just wearing around joe biden's
not particularly sentient face at this
point but that is pretty clear
that is pretty clear what sort of solid
support has come from this
administration for the cuban de center
so far
so far as i can see none by the way by
the way just your update on cuba the
the cuban forces are now arresting and
uh and unpersoning
pretty much all of the dissenters who
have been out in the streets
uh the world is becoming a dimmer place
under joe biden joe biden said america
was back no america is not back
america is back to the obama years were
we led from behind where we were in
america in retreat
on foreign policy and where we spent all
of our time naval gazing
about microaggressions in the united
states so as to pretend that the
great utopian program of the democrats
is somehow justified
and if you are offended by something
that you saw on facebook this means the
democrats get to radically expand the
size scope and power of government
in order to cure your personal ills
the undermining of american principles
and american rights continues
apace it is a shocking and disappointing
development the good news is that the
blowback has become democrats know which
is why they're getting so
rabid and hysterical about about
basically malign uh basically uh b9
voting laws
in places like texas and arizona and
georgia all right we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content
in the meantime go check out the
michaelmoles show that is available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pablo wydowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
texas democrats flee the state in order
to impede
election integrity bills robin
deangelo's new
anti-whiteness white racial theory book
totally flops
even though it's still being listed on
the new york times bestseller list
and the elite liberals are defending
socialism against
cuban protesters who actually have to
live under it check it out
on the michael knowles show